at glasgow central train station weary
delegates observers and activists
prepare to leave the cop 26 climate
summit is over an agreement reached
feelings mixed there were moments of
happiness
moments of progress moments of
frustration it has some good aspects in
it but it's also really not fulfilling
the science overall a great experience
got to meet a lot of interesting people
and yeah we're taking back some some
hopes and dreams we're always hoping for
more
because we know the climate emergency
and
honestly i don't think we're going fast
enough it's very difficult to come up
with agreements that are binding for
everyone
so you know today we rest and tomorrow
we organize again
the glasgow climate pact required
painful compromise like the last minute
push from india and china to weaken a
commitment to phase out coal
those
for whom climate change is already a
matter of life and death they demanded a
high level of ambition for this summit
and while many of us were willing to go
there
that wasn't true
of everybody and sadly that's the nature
of diplomacy
we can lobby we can control
we can encourage
but we cannot force sovereign nations
to do what they do not wish to do
divisions remain two over finance for
poorer nations already feeling the
effects of climate change they still
don't have enough funding to cope
still most decided that an imperfect
deal was better than nothing
the overarching aim of this summit was
to keep 1.5 degrees of global warming
within reach
that has happened
just and for it to stay that way
countries have agreed they must keep
increasing their ambitions every year
and that will be a major challenge
geopolitics and domestic political
pressures will continue to complicate
things it always does and at the next
cop and every single summit after the
threat from climate change will remain
and more will need to be done
hannah thomas peter sky news in glasgow